Now that we've implemented some d3 code and put what we learned about visual and
coding into practice I just wanted to recap where we are quickly.
In addition to being readily acceptable to a large audience,
d3 has a very nice API, or application programming interface.
This allows the library to function in a declarative manner.
Or rather, you tell d3 what you want,
not how you want it to accomplish the task.
By decoupling the specification of an operation from the execution of
that operation, d3 allows the user, you.
To focus on the specific application you're developing.
While still enabling engineers to possibly optimize the processing of
those operations.
Another interesting side effect of this is that the back end or
the graphics engine that d3 renders to could possibly be swapped out.
I mentioned d3 renders the SVG and HTML.
But you could imagine it rendering directly to HTML5 canvas or
even webGL for increased performance.
What do I mean by a declarative API exactly?
Well, for example, you do not need to tell the browser to draw a circle
at pixel 50 by 100, and then another circle at pixel 100 by 175.
And finally a line that connects these two circles.
For every data point you may have in let's say a JavaScript array repeat this
process and continue drawing circles and lines between them.
This process would be very tedious and possibly error-prone if for
every datum you have, you have to tell it exactly where to draw the circle.
And then, exactly how to draw the lines connecting them.